i am an imperfect man i made a mistake
and i own that chris harrison is
speaking out about his recent
racism controversy and his status with
the bachelor franchise
i plan to be back and i want to be back
the bachelor host appeared on good
morning america thursday
and opened up about defending rachel
curcanell
after she was accused of past racist
actions
i am an imperfect man i made a mistake
and i own that i believe
that mistake doesn't reflect who i am
or what i stand for
i am committed to the progress not just
for myself
also for the franchise harrison made
headlines last month after making
comments during an interview with former
bachelorette
rachel lindsay where he defended
kirkunel who was
accused of liking racist photos on
social media
bullying a woman for dating black men
and attending an
old south plantation party when she was
in college in 2018.
the picture was from 2018
at an old south antebellum party so i
think
you know when you hold that one well
rachel
is it a good look in 2018 or is it not a
good look in 2021
because there's a big difference ever
now harrison says he sees he was wrong
antebellum parties
are not okay past present
future knowing what that represents
is unacceptable and looking back at his
interview with lindsay
he says he's quote saddened and shocked
at how insensitive he was
i didn't speak for my heart and that is
to say i stand
against all forms of racism and i am
deeply sorry i'm sorry to rachel lindsey
and i'm sorry to the black community the
49 year old tv host said he has spoken
to lindsay since the interview
and apologized but he hasn't talked to
her since she deactivated her instagram
account last week after being bullied
and harassed
i talked to rachel not since she
deactivated her instagram account but i
talked to rachel initially and i
apologized
and i want to do so again i am
incredibly sorry to
anyone who is throwing hate
towards rachel lindsey please
stop it is unacceptable a lot of the
hate lindsey has been receiving stems
from people who think that harrison
is being treated unfairly but he insists
he's quote
not a victim here i made a mistake
and i own that racism
oppression these are big dynamic
problems and they take
serious work and i am committed to that
work
harrison also touched on his decision to
step aside from the franchise for a
period of time
but said he hopes to return i plan to be
back
and i want to be back this interview is
not the finish line
there is much more work to be done and i
am excited to be a part of that change
when controversy first erupted last
month harrison issued a statement
apologizing for quote wrongly speaking
in a manner that perpetuates racism
days later he released a second apology
announcing he'd be taking time away and
will not be hosting the after the final
rose special with current bachelor matt
james and his winning contestant
former nfl star and author of
uncomfortable conversations with a black
man
emmanuel acho will replace harrison as
host on the special airing
march 15th a source told et that the 30
year old
is ready for the job quote he feels
confident about replacing chris harrison
for the episode and believes he can lead
important conversations that viewers
should learn about and be part of
[Music]